I like to think of intense as envelopes
each one includes who or in this case
which component you want to deliver to
and there's room for a small amount of
data to be delivered packaged as extras
primitive tuples that will be available
to the application component that
ultimately receives and opens this
intent so an explicit intent explicitly
specifies the name of the recipient as
you can see on this envelope implicit
intents are rather more interesting here
we don't specify the name of the class
we don't even know what it is so how do
we indicate which activity to launch
well you know those stories you
sometimes hear about letters with vague
addresses like these that somehow still
find their way to the intended recipient
well the intent resolution system on
Android works the same way finding an
activity capable forming the action you
specify on the Associated data so rather
than specifying the name of a class you
indicate an action you'd like an
activity to perform and on what data
that action should be performed like
this where we want to address an
activity that's capable of viewing a
website and because intents can cross
through application boundaries the
activity that started may not be part of
your app so you can include
functionality like this browsing
websites or making phone calls or
choosing a contact from your address
book or from within your app without you
having to implement any of it yourself
you don't even need to know about the
app that will ultimately service your
request you can find details of some of
the intent supported by native apps in
common intents page of the Android
developer site